Jen what makes crime drama so popular
crime drama has been popular since the
beginning of time since Kan and abble
the very first murder so I I think I
have lots of theories on why it's so
popular I think that one theory is in
our daily lives we encounter a lot of
mystery right like I know in my life
there's a lot of unexplained things
whether it's relational things or things
for my past or questions that I have
there's just always mystery and I I
think too like we're as humans and
especially modern humans we're not very
comfortable with mystery anymore like we
want answers for everything want
everything to make sense but in real
life it doesn't there there's a lot of
mystery that we deal with in real life
and crime dramas give us the opportunity
to explore mystery and solve it so that
the end of the the day we don't have the
Myster has been solved there's that
catharsis in like I've got the answers
it was figured out um so I think that's
one huge
reason and one other reason I think
crime dramas are so popular is because I
believe we have this really
innate sense of justice and Redemption
that we're born with that like we want
to see Justice we want things to be
redeemed that are not are unfair or that
are
injust uh we want to see chaos ordered
there's a lot of Chaos in the world we
want to see we just have this innate
desire to see all of that ordered and
writed and the wrongs writed and and
Justice and we again we don't always get
to see that every day in our real lives
we live sort of sometimes in
chaotic situations or um bad things
happen that don't get always get
redeemed but in crime
dramas chaos is ordered the wrongs are
writed we get Justice we get that
redemption in that world and I think it
gives us a really great
catharsis why do you think some stories
are more popular than others I'm
thinking of like the Black Dalia things
that over time every generation seems to
be interested in yeah that's so great
such a great
question I weirdly right we have the
fash fascination with sort of very the
grotesque and the
unusual
and um the barbaric honestly I mean look
at dmer right Jeffrey dmer and now the
popularity of that whole series and the
Black Dalia is classic case of that too
um I don't know I think that's just kind
of innate too in who we are and as
humans that it's so bizarre right and
outside
of
what we know should
be um human
dignity and I guess we're kind of drawn
to that and why does that happen and why
does that happen to certain people and
what CA and the people who caused that
who are these people um sort of the
whole mystery around all of that I think
it will always
be always have that question of why
lingering over it you know why her why
that woman why in that way and who would
have done that and same with you know
any other kind of very popular sort
of uh eccentric murder I guess is a
polite way to say it what is your
favorite crime mystery story like is
there a certain show certain book I have
so
many
um okay I got to think that's a really
good question I have so
many
um I don't know that I could say like by
name what my favorite is but I'm very
interested
in
stories um that have a psychological
nature to them um that explore the
Criminal Mind I'm very interested in
historical you know things uh Crim
criminality I guess in the past criminal
nature and how it was
resolved in in history in like 100 years
plus ago
um
I like anybody I like I just I have a
fascination with these serial killers
too like what makes like mine Hunters is
one of my favorite um of of late of the
last few years books and series because
I love how it
explored the mind of the serial killer
and how that that Behavioral Science
evolved so I like that I think that's a
very
fascinating um a very fascinating aspect
of human psychology and criminality to
explore um I tend not to
like I I shouldn't say like I tend not
to absorb or consume a lot of like cozy
mystery or lighter I don't know what
that says about me I love comedy but not
not when it pertains to criminality I
guess I don't know
um yeah let's I'm trying to think what
do I watch what do I read
um but I do like I do like the Corky
like um there was a series while back
Veronica Mars I think that was a lot of
fun and I think that coming of age and
kind of teen crime solving is fun um
Pushing Daisies was very fun I I like I
think just because it was in a very
quirky world it was more about the
quirkiness of the world and the
characters more so than the crimes the
nature of the
crimes do you think we as viewers want
to see um a show that surprises us or
read a book that surprises us or do we
as the viewer or the reader want to be
two steps
ahead I think it depends on what kind of
person you
are
uh I I think it has a lot to do with
yeah with personality type and and what
some people are big puzzle solvers right
and they want to be two steps two steps
ahead and some people want to go for the
ride and just be sort of carried along
and and really get into the world and
the characters and sort of be surprised
and see what happens I really think it
completely depends on your personality
so I'm thinking back to like uh Unsolved
Mysteries yeah that it was the kind of
show that they would just give you
little vignettes or little Snippets of a
story but it had you thinking like who
and what and would leave you with these
questions and yeah that was it was like
a puzzle that's a great way to say it
yeah exactly do you think the rise in uh
like crime podcast through crime
podcasts or uh
shows in some sense can hurt the
families of the victims or is it in in a
sense helpful because information can be
crowdsourced and it could lead to
solving the crime right um it's always a
fine line I know that investigators are
always kind of walking that fine line um
of how much to reveal and how much the
public gets to know or doesn't get to
know
[Music]
um
I I never thought about that question
actually
um I believe that criminal science and
forensics
are
art as well as
science so it's a constantly
evolving art form SL science techniques
right so it's kind of like medicine
medicine today looks very different than
it did 100 years ago it's a constantly
evolving science it's also an art um my
dad who's a physician always used to say
look medicine is more art sometimes than
science because we're con everybody's
body is different and and medicines
react differently and certain treatments
will react differently sometimes
depending on the person and I think it's
kind of that way Case by case um with
these crime podcasts and all the crime
cases that are being sort of shown into
the light through film TV podcasts all
of this a lot of these are cold cases
things that happen have happened a while
ago and so when you look at perhaps how
they were solved 5 10 15 20 30 40 years
ago then you have to look at it under
the lens of what was Crim solving like
and what were the techniques available
at that time versus now because so you
see where I'm going with this it's like
it's very much it can be helpful
sometimes because we didn't always have
certain things then that we do now um
and I think it can be helpful because so
maybe some there are sometimes criminals
who were put away who shouldn't have
been because of certain things witness
testimonies or DNA that wasn't processed
properly or whatever the the case may be
so
um I think that if there's a legitimate
reason to bring the case to light if
there are a lot of question marks
because again it was probably you know
more an art than a science
then that's can be a good thing um for
for the justice system for the families
um E I think though either way there's
going to be how do I
say there's always going to be people
who in this process of digging up all
these cases and looking at things again
who may feel
disenfranchised or they're being wronged
all over again um that maybe they're
being
revictimized um or that are maybe V
angry because their loved ones killer
was put away and now they're digging
something up to say wait you're now
you're going to try to free them that's
a ve that can be a very
unsettling uh experience so I think that
will always be the case because you're
you're stirring up something that maybe
other people have put to
rest what makes a great crime drama when
I first started writing crime dramas I
asked myself the same question what
makes a great crime drama and I couldn't
find a lot of resources so I started
watching binging watching watching
watching to find out yeah what does make
what makes for a good crime drama what
are the ingredients because I'm very
like I love to cook I love to bake so I
think in terms of ingredients so I came
up with this formula this recipe I think
basically I I'll give you the
ingredients how we put them together I
think is what really makes you know a
sule better than another sule but uh I
think first of all you start with this
thing called Mom what I call Mom and Pop
so like the foundation of every good
family as a mother and a father uh mom
and pop points of proof are what law
enforcements start with when they're
investigating a case and points of proof
are Mom means opportunity and motive
so really thinking through those three
things whenever I start a new to write a
new or develop a new crime drama I kind
of pretend like I'm making the case file
for my story and my crime and I start
with the way a detective would um so
what were the means opportunity and
motive of my criminal and I do a pretty
deep dive into that I'm not talking just
like one word like I really go deep into
what was the crime and why was it
especially why was it committed
um and then of course you have things
like you have to have crime you have to
know the crimes there's usually more
than one crime that happens so like what
is your series of crimes how does that
build um
there's always um then there's like
obstacles and these are really just
story elements as well but there have to
be specific obstacles at certain points
along the way that relate to how the
criminal and the protagonist you know
kind of do the cat and mouse game I
think too there
are I I believe and I think this is
probably the most important ingredient I
believe that the source or the
foundation of every great Crime Story is
rooted in
love and it could be a familial love
like a parent child or or two brothers
um it could be romantic love it could be
just an Agape like a friendship platonic
kind of love it could even be maybe a
selflove a person who's trying to um
forgive themsel for something or come
more into themself become more um a
better person or the best version of
themsel but there's always I think when
you look at every great Crime Story it's
always rooted in love look at Breaking
Bad it starts because Walter White wants
to take care of his family it's familial
love that's the entire basis of every of
whatever he the whole thing why why he
does what he does prisoners I don't know
if you ever saw prisoners it's a film by
elcon entertainment Hugh Jackman and
Jake jenal that is also familial love
everything that Hugh Jackman does to try
to solve this crime uh is completely
based in love for his daughter um anyway
monk the TV show monk he comes back to
the force because he wants to avenge his
wife's death his death wife was murdered
and he wants to figure out how wants to
solve that case because of his love for
her so I think once you nail that once
you figure that out with your
protagonist that to me is sort of the
basis of a really great crime story and
then you add all the other stuff you
know your case File your obstacles your
CRI your crimes your motive means
opportunity um I think you need to
Pepper in some of the story there story
tropes for Crime genre that you just
sort sort of have to put in there you
know like maybe something blows up a bad
guy who's turns good or a good guy turns
bad you know there's there's always at
the end of act two always uh you need to
put your hero's life in danger you know
the protagonist who's trying to catch
this criminal almost dies right that
whiff of death moment and I think you
need a little bit of Gallow humor I
think that's kind of like a little salt
and pepper that you need to put into it
and then of course character
um I think that all these great crime
stories are like when you look at any of
the Hitchcock stories they have amazing
protagonists um and even the ones of
modern um the the protagonists are
really Dexter Walter White they're all
very um very very layered characters and
so I go through like a whole exercise to
help myself um really layer who is this
not just a detective or a an
investigator it's like there's got to be
a lot
more to this character then they just
want to solve crimes like why are they
solving why are they doing this you know
what is why did they pick this thing to
do versus another thing to do so
character um of course is is
key what kinds of characters do we most
often see in crime dramas any kinds of
characters
any any any kinds of characters are in
crime dramas and that's because I think
you have um uh when I teach on this I
teach on 11 crime story types and I kind
of go through again when I was binge
watching years ago all these crime
stories I started to notice oh they all
kind of fall into like certain story
types like there's the traditional cop
there's the forensic specialist there's
the profiler um there's the Caper you
know there's all these 11 and so what I
realized in doing that is like literally
anybody can be an investigator you have
a whole like amateur amateur detective
amateur sleuth category so it could be a
plumber it could be a librarian you know
um Girl with the Dragon Tattoo she's not
a professional law enforcement she's a
computer
hacker uh Murder She Wrote right just a
writer just just you know in a small
town so really the protagonists can be
anybody Walter White was High School
teacher right um so I think that's
what's so great and then like if you get
into like Supernatural crime stories uh
like Supernatural I think they were
brothers if I remember right I haven't
seen it for a while but they can be
anybody you have like the ex files they
it's really kind of uh stranger things
it's a bunch of kids but they are
solving a crime they are solving a
supernatural crime that's going on in
their community so really can be anybody
which is why I think this genre is so
widely appealing like is really
something for
everybody what's usually at
stake uh yeah what's always at
stake you know how you know again as
writers were're like okay what does the
character want what does the character
need and it's like these two storylines
always flowing together the external
goal and then the internal goal so the
external goal is
99.9% of the time to catch the killer to
solve the case that's what the
protagonist wants they want to you know
restore the world to Justice redeem that
world order the chaos right the
internal drive is always the same it's
always the same overall goal it's just
different depending on who that
character is but it's and this is why I
think that um these grab people so much
well any great story will grab people
the internal goal for any protagonist um
or the internal need I should say is if
they don't get that thing if they don't
solve that case or get that thing that
they're after um because of whatever is
going on inside they will lose their
soul they will absolutely lose their
soul it's always like to say um there
are worse things than death death is not
the worst thing that can happen to us
losing our soul is the worst thing that
can happen to us and I think that's why
when you find these really great stories
whether they're end up being you know
heroic stories or more tragic stories
again back to Breaking Bad um the thing
that Walter White's going to lose if he
doesn't provide for his family is his
soul he's he will have lost a lot of
other things but at the the core of
himself he would have it's like he would
have failed completely completely lose
his soul if he doesn't you know step up
and do this so that's what I think is
always at stake so there has to be a
core of
obsession in in in the character that's
trying to solve the crime whoever that
is whether it's like a an actual
detective or a citizen journalist or
somebody there's like this they just
like their whole life will fall apart if
they don't interesting okay yeah I think
so um okay let's look at sharper sharp I
always want to say sharper objects oh
that's a good one that's the second one
yeah right right right exactly and then
sharpest yeah go third one yeah Trilogy
um so in sharp objects so let's look at
and I forget the I'm so bad with the
names but Amy Adam was like her
character you know she's coming back to
this small town to really unravel this
horrific event that happened and she's
also struggling right herself she's
basically an alcoholic if I remembering
that correctly and so she knows I think
we see in her that she knows if she
can't get out of this cycle of
alcoholism she's going to lose herself
she's going to lose her soul um the only
way out of that is she's got to uncover
all this stuff that's been going on back
home that she tried to run away from so
if she never ever ever in her entire
life solves that she'll never become
whole she'll lose her
soul right and it's a great opening too
because um it hints at some of the stuff
that she went through and then she
presents to her editor or I forget if
how the how it goes down whether he
presents to her or she presents to him
and she goes back and it's so wonderful
it's it is on so many levels and he's
that Mentor like constantly challenging
her right because he knows she's going
to lose her soul if she doesn't press
forward and she does be it does become
an obsession for her because there's a
certain point at which she's kind of
sort of a reluctant here at points or
you see her wanting to pull back but
then there's a point where she goes full
in because and it does become more of an
obsession because
she does realize if she does for many I
mean there's the external like I've got
to do this for everyone around me too
and save them but if I don't do it I'm
I'm going to be lost forever my my whole
being is lost so it does become an
obsession sure and it also too it has a
lot of baggage for her to go back
because if I'm remembering correctly she
grew up in in Wind Gap and so she kind
of has you know bitter feelings but also
some memories that were bad and some
that were you know it's was her whole
being that was back there exactly and
she has to go back and face that and
then redeem it she has to redeem it
somehow what's a good test to see if
something is missing from your story
whether there's there's not enough
Intrigue the suspects don't seem real
the stakes aren't high enough it's very
common problem especially in first
couple drafts to have things not as
suspenseful or falling flat or not
making things as challenging on your
investigator as you should it's very
common so first of all give yourself
some Grace take a breath I like to
Workshop my work I always Workshop my
work because even if I think maybe
there's enough suspense and Challenge
and mystery and authenticity uh my
writers group will definitely point out
if there's not and that's good it's good
to have that accountability so I I'm a
big proo proponent of writer groups
and uh community in in writing because
once you find the right Community you'll
you'll start to well your work will get
a lot stronger
because and you don't have to rely so
much on your
yourself because they'll Point things
out for you and that's really helpful
although sometimes painful but really
helpful so then the question becomes how
do I fix this all right it's falling
flat things aren't as
suspenseful I like to make sure that
there are op stles
intention in every
scene and so when I'm going back through
to edit second or third draft or more
that's one of my checklists I want to
see if there's
something t t like a tension happening
at the end of each scene like a little
baby even if it's just a little baby
Cliffhanger we just or little baby
mystery you're leaving us with something
unresolved in almost every scene it
could be an emotional element right
between characters or a relational
element uh it could be more something to
do with the case at
hand when in order to make sure that's
not happening with the case or like to
make sure you're I like I again this is
why I love making a case File because I
can clock I'm going to clock that trail
of evidence from the beginning to the
end and I'm going to before I even get
to the script or the page I'm going to
make go through and as
if I'm the criminal committing the crime
and then I'm the investigator
investigating the crime and I want to
make sure that the trails of evidence
make sense and that they have a lot of
tension and I want to make sure
that um my criminals smart and my
investigators is really smart um so for
me it's a lot of
pre-work to see that that's all
happening and it really just kind of
takes practice too you kind of write a
lot of Limp things before things start
to really sing um and then sort of
innately you get a sense like oh this is
if your guts kind of telling you like
yeah this is just
isn't there's just not enough tension
here there's just nothing really
happening there's not enough suspense I
think it's important to listen to that
as well because 10 times out of 10 that
there's a problem there I Rely a lot on
my instinct and the more you write the
sharper Your Instinct becomes I think if
you're serious about it
um I mean it's it's such a great
question because I'm trying to think
over the 20 years I've been doing this
how did I learn that and it was really a
lot
of it wasn't a book learning you know it
really wasn't a thing that I read in a
book or watched in a video or took a
class on you know it was very much just
practicing the craft knowing first of
all what goes into a great Crime Story
what makes it sing what makes it pop
what makes it binge worthy and then
testing it out on my writer group and
then just in using my instinct your
story Instinct really I guess I like
that I would call it that's good that
could be a book too story ins that's
good I like that good you put the
crossbones and things yeah the case File
that you begin is this a metaphorical
file where you'll do it on your computer
or do you actually have like a manila
folder where you create like your own
sheet with different pieces of evidence
and log things and that would be super
fun I've never done that but that would
be really fun um I yeah usually just
start everything by hand I'll write
notes and notes and notes by hand and
then it ends up on my computer and just
becomes a computer file you know where
I've sort of done all the exercise of
the case so but I kind of like yeah
creating an actual case File that'd be
fun create your own evidence
pieces yeah there's your interactive
game yeah so you're doing this as if you
are the investigator from the POV of the
investigator first the investigator then
the criminal or vice vers I mean you can
do it either way but um I try to take
both points of view like okay if I'm the
criminal and I want to create a crime
I'm going to commit a crime I'm going to
walk myself through it from the
beginning to post and then what did I do
how did that happen and then as an
investigator I could say oh I'm coming
I've just been thrown into this I have
to investigate this crime um what from
the the beginning to the end of solving
it what am I coming across um because
right we in the real world um you know a
detective or a investigator may not find
everything um which is really I think
good we want we don't want our main we
don't want our heroes to find everything
either but I need to know both I as the
Creator as the goddess of this world I
need to know both I don't know use
everything it's probably not wise to use
everything because otherwise it'd be
just like a game of matching right it'd
be too easy but I need to
know what I need to know from both
points of view what happened uh so that
I
can successfully play that cat and mouse
game with them if that makes sense
almost like a chess game it does and you
know speaking of which you mentioned the
you know the investigator doesn't always
have everything in real life when a case
turns cold quote unquote is it because
there's not enough evidence there's not
enough
funding what's the usual reason why a
case is sort of tucked away right
there's a lot of reasons um a case
officially becomes cold after 12
months so then it goes into that
designation so during that first 12
months it gets you know a lot of
attention um it could be because there's
just not enough evidence that leads to a
particular person of interest uh a lot
of times there's not enough person power
to investigate there's not enough funds
these police departments are severely
underfunded there's not enough people um
there's yeah it's all of these things
that happen um there's a lot of cold
cases in our in our country a lot and oh
really just there yeah really kind of
Fizzles out because of sort of a uh
combination of all those
things and doesn't mean that it won't
ever get solved but it it needs at some
point a little boost of something
whether it's a person just going further
into investigating to make those
connections money for that person to do
that um and then of course you know when
a crime happens that's not the end like
then crimes keep happening so then the
workload right there's a constant
workload coming in every day it's not
like you can just stop solve that crime
well and you know put a pause on the
world pause everybody no more crimes a
second I got to solve this one there's
constantly more and more stacking up so
it's uh it's a workload problem as
well and are there some nonprofits that
you can kind of different people can
sort of crowdsource their efforts to
solve cold cases mhm there are there are
and
um different you know there's all
there's actually a probably lots lots of
them I got involved with the Cold Case
Foundation uh they are a National
Organization that's a nonprofit and they
really solve the hardest to solve cases
they it's it's free you know they're all
but funded through um donations and you
know not any sort of outside
other you know agency money or anything
like that and and so there are
organizations like that like them that
will help people um they are awesome and
they are growing and they rely a lot on
retired law enforcement and retired
investigators to come in and volunteer
their time to which I think is awesome
because you have you know people coming
in who have Decades of of information
you know knowledge about how to do this
and the time so and the intuition and
the intuition yeah interesting what's
better a victim we can root for in a
story or a villain we can love to
hate depends on the story type of the 11
crime story types that I talk about and
teach there's one Crime Story type
that's different than all the rest and
that's called the Caper and this is a
very very popular fun Crime Story type
because in that crime story type We are
rooting for the villain the villain is
our hero the villain is the bad guy and
we love to root for the villain
because typically the villain has been
wronged in their past and now they're
taking Justice into their own hands and
we're like yes right because how many
times have maybe we been wronged and we
couldn't do anything about it and we
just would have loved to take justice in
our own own hands and like avenge our
our crime or our Mis Injustice or and so
this we love this crime story type so I
I don't think it's an either or
situation I think there's just sometimes
we love this we love this crime story
type of rooting for the villain um Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid classic
example Fon L Weise classic example we
just write like one of my favorites um
heler high water which came out a few
years ago be has quickly be and was kind
of quiet like just kind of came and went
but it's brilliant Caper about familial
love rooted in familial love about two
brothers who commit crimes in order to
avenge their mother's wrong something
that bad that happened to their mother
right who's not going to root for that
even though they're they're doing ter
Terrible Things um all of the oceans
movies are Caper Italian job and and
those villains it's more of a team right
it's more of a multiple
um it's a I say it's a team sport but
you know a character team of characters
and they're just kind of fun I don't I
think there's maybe some avenging that
goes on definitely in the Italian job
but in the oceans 11 one like it's it's
really just fun to watch them get away
with this big crime and sort of mess
with the system
so uh that is I think in its own just
the story type that we
love
um separate from but not necessarily
unequal from the stories where we get
very invested in the victims and we want
to see them it's just a different story
type um where you're focusing more on
the victim's story and how does that get
resolved and redeemed and so I just
think they're very they're just kind of
different but not necessar necessarily
one is better than the other I guess
so yeah what makes a satisfying
ending I believe that a satisfying
ending does not necessarily have to be a
closed happy everything gets wrapped up
in a little bow but it needs to be
cathartic in
that
whatever un Injustice was set at the
beginning needs to be writed whatever
chaos happened to this person at the
beginning needs to somehow be ordered um
there has to be an element of redemption
in even if it's just a little bit we can
see that the world is just a little bit
brighter for that person that hero or
that victim um I think that's the
catharsis we're all looking for in this
genre and that we're all looking for for
in ourselves our world our own
worlds and would it depend you said
earlier like cozy Mysteries okay that's
more maybe light-hearted and in the end
you know the the the sun will shine
again and and there's Harmony restored
to the neighborhood but maybe girl with
a dragon tattoo not so much right right
right right I mean you have the the
Hallmark Mysteries which are Super
popular right and they're great and like
could binge watch those all
day those in the Christmas movies um and
that's there's definitely a place for
that it's lovely um and then you have
something more like what happens on
lifetime which is definitely the more
the genre of women's stories and women
wanting to be a event like wanting to
have right right restored because um bad
things have happened to them and so
there's that sort of a little bit darker
level um of story yeah and then we can
go silence the Lambs or
um what did you just say uh with the
drag tattoo yes where which I I love
Swedish Noir I love n that that Nordic
Noir um love it it's because it's you're
right it doesn't there is a a satisfying
ending in that she helps them catch this
horrible person who's been trafficking
women it's horrifying you know kind of
really dark and grizzly
but she does help avenge all that and so
it's extremely
satisfying um
ending but you you know you kind of get
muddy getting there getting to the end
of
that and the writer has his own
interesting story too and mystery behind
his death oh did he I didn't read about
that well there's different theories but
anyway can Google that I have no yeah I
have no opinion on either one but um
yeah there's been mystery behind
oh I love
it what are the first steps in writing a
crime drama to write a crime drama you
first need to know how story works
really well because crime dramas are
left brain right brain you have to know
exactly The
Logical um plot right you your plot and
your Trails of evidence have to make
sense not just for your hero your
investigator but also for your criminal
your criminal definitely needs his or
her own very structured story but then
there's the whole other emotional
element relational element to the story
that you need to to know how to tell
well because that's the thing that keeps
that keeps is the page Turner that's the
thing that keeps you coming back after
the commercials or binge the next uh
episode you is that that underlying the
humanity behind all of it right um that
your investigators need and even um I
think we've come a long way when I look
at like TV from the 80s and 90s to now
even criminals
have been it's never black and white
like white right it's it's like we used
to be able to get get away with like the
bad guy and sort of this stereotypic
thing but it's we are not bad guys are
not black and white um criminals are not
Black and White in real life there's
layers and layers to why they got to
where they did and so uh those two
things un un layering those for your
protagonist and your criminal are the
for me the foundations like that's where
you have to start you have to know how
to tell story really well and then how
to really think
through these two major chest
pieces
so what should happen the first 10
pages of a crime Thriller drama what's
crucial kind of the same as really any
story set up um you're setting things up
you're setting up your crime you
typically not you're because you're
introducing oh we're this is a crime
genre we're going to tell you about a
crime that happened so you're setting up
your crime your criminal World your
criminal you're setting up your
investigator and his or her world and
what that looks like sometimes
investigators are professional sometimes
they're not um what is sometimes they're
this is their job and so that innately
gives them a motive for having to
investigate something a lot of times
they're not they're maybe reluctant
heroes or they get thrown into a
situation where they're sort of forced
uh to investigate something and then you
know become more obsessed about it
but that's it's really kind of yeah the
first 10 pages it's really the same as
setting up any story um your main your
main characters and your world and the
tone what kind of ride we're going to go
on the if you would look at the pilot of
Pushing Daisies which is very fun right
very quirky fun kind of Crime Story
versus uh you know Dexter pilot it's the
Tone's very different right so you're
setting that up too right away I think
you've said to start your story in the
middle of things come in late leave
early why is that in media raise just
yeah start in the middle of things it's
I mean really I think for any story you
want to do this but I think it's really
important for this type of story because
you are constantly trying to build
tension and suspense and you want to
come in late and leave early so that
helps you um build that that pacing that
tension you don't want extra really
obviously like in any script there's not
room for extraneous right you only want
what's on the page or on the screen to
be there and nothing else it I think
it's like tenfold for crime stories if
you're especially if the tone is to is
less relationship relational less
comedic and more about the action The
Thrill The Adventure the suspense the
tension because you're really you don't
want to leave any room you want to just
keep it super tight and keep us on that
ride you know
fast okay so with if we could use an
example so let's say trying to think of
the beginning of sharp objects but we're
not necessarily seeing all the mundane
of her life we're speeding it up right I
mean bra yes exactly um you're only
going to see and honestly that's a great
um that's a great way of putting it
because you really are trying to build
for your protagonist you're really
trying to build in the motive right what
is driving them personally let's just
take professionally off the table
because um especially for like
detectives like that is their job so the
motive the there's a different kind of
motive because the motive is like that's
your job here's your case you know oh
that's today's job um but for like
sharper objects she doesn't have to take
this um and even like Breaking Bad in
the pilot the first 10 minutes we're
really seeing what Walter White's we're
right in the middle of the abyss of his
life at this moment when he's just at it
lowest of his low like he's found out
he's going to die and he's he's not
respected at school he's not respected
outside of school so we're seeing that
setup of that motive of why he's going
to delve into the world of crime
criminal activity so we're setting it up
really fast and in multiple um little
scenes um so I
think that's a really because we don't
it's and he's he's definitely more of
the Caper kind so it's a little bit
different than a traditional detective
kind of crime story but even with the
traditional detectives you're seeing
right away um they're getting launched
into
this crime right and they have to go on
the scene and right away there they
trying to evaluate everything they're
right in the middle of this chaos
somebody's just been murdered and this
is a chaotic world and what do we know
we have to Quick figure out what we know
so you're given you're they you're given
as an audience and them as an
protagonist are given just the pieces
they need at that moment to propel them
to the next scene and then the next
scene and the next scene one of the
things that's
tempting for people who are newer in
writing this genre and I'm just as I was
guilty of this is just wanting to throw
all the evidence up front you know
within that first 10 or 20 Pages we
don't need that we don't we shouldn't
have that it's it's a rabbit Trail and
so we're going to lay carrots all the
way through to the very end so you're
only giving
your your Heroes exactly what they need
in the moment to just get to the next
step to figure out the next step and
then the next step and then the next
step and of course obstacles are going
to get thrown in their way and bounce
them around so so we don't want to make
it too easy for the reader or the viewer
to solve and at times maybe throw them
off keep them guessing yeah I definitely
you don't want it to be easy for your
hero I always think about I don't want
it to be easy for my hero because um
that makes that person kind of boring
and not very good at his job or her job
um and it makes them not very human so
they may do things they may make
mistakes um there's definitely I I
always say like you definitely want
rabbit trails that don't pan out they
find a piece of evidence and it doesn't
pan out um they talk to a witness that
they think oh my goodness I just solved
the case or this is it we got what we
need and it doesn't work out so you
definitely want that for for your hero
also for your also of course for your
audience yep yeah you want to take them
on the ride
so why do you say limit physical
evidence to three to five pieces I do I
do say there there are six basic types
of evidence in the world that you can
use not just for writers but for instest
real investigators and physical evidence
there are three types of physical
evidence physical evidence is especially
DNA because we've come so far with DNA
right now I first of all my rule of
thumb is never solve a case with DNA
that was okay in the '90s when DNA was
evolving and and it was like this bright
shiny new thing but now it's too easy
and DNA is just too good it's so good so
um that Will was just too easy I think
for story
story-wise and I say limit
your overall physical evidence 3 to five
because while those are interesting
Trails of evidence and we need them to
connect the dots to from our crime to
our
criminal it's they're not they they can
a lot of times they can be easily
resolved uh because you're you know
you're looking at Tang Like A Shard of
glass okay of course eventually they're
going to find out okay it's this kind of
glass and it came from that window and
that church on that street okay great we
connected those dots awesome but what's
more interesting story-wise is
circumstantial evidence and that's all
that indirect evidence what people think
or here or or infer it's that gray area
and if you look at like go back to sharp
objects
most of that is solved through
circumstantial evidence piecing together
memories piecing together where people
were at certain times piecing together
what people said or heard or what it's
it's not it's there's a there are
physical pieces of evidence but it's
it's mostly connected through
circumstantial evidence and I think
that's what
makes for good tension because and
suspense and gray area in story
and unless you're writing a very um a
very straight
forensic kind of story type which is
great I mean we have those and we we all
love them um bones is a great example of
that CSI and NCIS those are really fun
and they've been on the air forever
they're Classics um and but they deal
very strongly in in physical evidence
but I think that the circumstantial that
other gray area
is really interesting to play around
with with your
characters
and that's why I say try to limit your
physical evidence and really focus on
pulling out character
character and how character plays
into um creating your Trails of
evidence if that makes sense do is is
direct evidence the same as physical
evidence direct
is things like photographs video witness
testimony it's not really physical
evidence it's not really circumstantial
evidence uh so
videos photographs those are fun to use
but they're pretty they're direct right
they're pretty this is what you get if
if somebody videotapes somebody doing
something well it's pretty hard to
dispute that unless you you know can
figure out some ways to to trip that up
um witness testimony can be very gray or
it can be very clear you can really play
it both ways so what about say let's
suppose you have a small town
everybody's got their own
agenda small towns are filled with
gossip right and everybody kind of has
her own angle whether it's positive or
negative right where does hearsay fall
into yeah that would be more
circumstantial type of evidence what
people are
inferring um what they're sort of
concluding based on you know whatever
biases or things they think they have
seen or heard or you know so but but I
love it that's definitely uh what should
be happening in your Mysteries um broad
Church uh I don't know if you know this
British series and then they made it
into a US series and I can never
remember the name of the US one uh that
really plays a lot on that what you just
said that everybody's got a different
angle in town and a different I saw this
and I did this and he said this and um
that's fun a lot of fun are Mysteries
better served in a small town
environment
I don't think it
matters I think again
its setting its
tone
um we can have very well okay I'll say
this because I'm from a small town so
I'm very partial to small small town
Mysteries because of exactly what we
were just talking about with the
circumstantial and the hearsay and um
people are very tightly connected a lot
of times in small towns
and um it's
hard it's harder to be inconspicuous
it's harder to hide things in a small
town you are known so that's a whole one
element to play with in terms of if you
what kind of setting and tone you're
giving your mystery in bigger cities
it's it's easy to disappear it's easy to
be incon you know just to hide away and
nobody knows you it's um it's so that's
a whole different right tone and setting
and but also
there's I don't know it's that that
lends its own kind of interesting
mystery right because you could be as a
killer you could be killing a lot of
people in a big city and it could take a
long time before somebody caught you
because you're an unknown um whereas in
a small town it's harder to hide from
that sort of behavior I guess so it
probably just depends too like what kind
of crimes you want to explore um it's of
course bigger cities you're dealing you
can deal deal with bigger crimes in
terms of like a criminal World a bigger
criminal world like Mafia or a gambling
ring whereas in a smaller town that's
going to be harder to hide it's still
happening probably but it's going to be
a little trickier
to hide that to hide a mafia ring in a
small town although maybe there's
something to that maybe there should be
a show about
that like uh the cwad movie did you see
I did see that yeah and I thought that
was really interesting because she
couldn't there were all these rumors
about the quote unquote Marsh girl yeah
true or untrue and and so it was just uh
I thought that was a great yeah and and
some of the the best scenes were her
just kind of like storming through town
yeah and um the the the shopkeepers you
know craning their neck and things like
that to see oh there she is you know
right yeah this little fish out of water
and everybody's got their thoughts and
theories about her and I guess that
would really be a caper that story
because we are rooting for our criminal
the entire
time mhm don't want to give spoilers
away but too bad if you haven't seen it
by now or read the
book I've heard of 30 years and then you
can give away 30 oh no that's too long
that's too long okay how did digital
forensics factor into
storytelling I know this is great
question I've been actually exploring
this whole world of digital forensics
for a while
because again it's really emerged as a
SC a science a thing in the real world
within the last 10 years and become you
know electronic forensics be very huge
field now especially with identity theft
and all that I'm think it's how do we
explore that I think it's challenging
because again like it's all happening on
screen or inside of a computer code
right and Visually it's just not that
exciting to watch so I think it has to
you know
whatever and also a lot a lot of people
me included I don't understand coding I
don't understand how criminal I don't
understand that world of criminal
activity I don't because I don't know
I'm not a computer scientist I never
studied computers science uh I never
studied coding I don't know how to do
any of that so and a lot of people don't
so that knowledge is something then as a
writer if you're going to draw us into
that world you're going to have to make
it accessible to us and you're going to
really have to rely on the character's
stories at this point in history anyway
you know where we're at now this may be
different in 10 years but it has to
really still go back to the very strong
basics of story and your hero and your
antagonist and really showing
us what they are doing H how they are
doing it and the stakes and that is an
interesting challenge when the whole
world of that is inside a computer right
and a microchip or on a in on a screen
so I I haven't figured this out quite
yet how to make that completely
interesting in terms of if that were
your whole criminal world I think
Hollywood's probably still figuring it
out because I haven't seen any shows or
a lot of movies that I can even pinpoint
that that where that's the focus that's
the main Crim solving Focus even though
in the real world that's people's entire
jobs is just to break down criminals on
the web or dark web or whatever um so
it's a
huge huge
growing criminal world that's out there
in
reality I'm curious to see how we
translate that to a fictional
World um yeah that's I'm waiting to see
also phones phon geolocation of phones
and and you know you said talked about
you know
circumstantial evidence of someone's
location well now if someone's phone
pinged a certain Tower maybe they had
them phone in their possession and like
that yeah that's that's um definitely
see a lot of that like using technology
or people's technology to track them or
to track a killer or figure out their
last steps in life where were they like
that
definitely yeah that's used all the time
and um um again that's I guess I would
call that physical
evidence um because it's very tangible
it's very maybe it's a combination of
physical and direct and so it's really
easy to prove right like oh their phone
was here and this Tower is here these
are all tangible very real things so
again
like use some
sparingly of the 11 types of crime
stories which is the most difficult to
write and why I just think that depends
on who you are because they all are very
there's like legal there's paranormal
there's medical mystery there's um
profiler I think I said before
traditional cop the Caper I'm missing a
few but it really depends on what kind
if you're creating this it depends on
what kind of world do you want to live
in like I don't love the legal world I
don't love watching legal shows I don't
really know a lot about I don't like
care too much about that legal world so
I will for me that would be really hard
if someone was like write a legal crime
drama I'd be like so much research ah um
I just it just doesn't thrill me um so
it I really just has to depend it really
just depends on who the person is
creating it what kind of world they
really want to spend time in um like the
medical exam
uh investigation Corner that's a whole
another Crime Story type with shows like
rosoli and is and Quincy and I I feel
very comfortable in that World um
because I lived that world so but
whereas someone else might be like e i
that's not the world for me so I think
it just depends on what world do you
want to spend time
in yeah what happens when you get stuck
in a story how do you get yourself
unstuck whether it's a novel screenplay
MH I
research I take a shower I take a walk I
call a
friend
I I let it rest sometimes and I do maybe
go do something else for a while
and I can say that it always help any
one of those options gets me
unstuck yeah I've never been yeah if I
try it yeah I just have to try something
will work I know it will work so so it's
good to have hobbies that are you know
if you're writing about sort of a Dark
World maybe hobbies that are a little
lighter and fun and you said you like
comedies yeah I think so I mean even
something as simple as like I'll just
like I don't know go vacuum or you're
just doing something completely
different than that that you're not
thinking about the story um but yeah
when I unwind I mean I love I love to
read I read a lot of non-fiction I I
love I've been getting more into reading
more crime fiction um rather than
viewing so much and so I do love to be
in that genre just to stay up in what's
what's happening and what are the new
stories and but honestly in my spare
time I'm GNA put a comedy on 100% of the
time I'm gonna watch Ted lasso over and
over who's the best person to tell the
story are you doing first person
narrator third person I
let the protagonist tell me I know that
sounds like so woo woo writerly but I've
told stories from first person I've told
from
third I've told both my book H in the
woods I have I think six or seven
different points of you uh that are all
working through that novel so and that's
just kind of how it came out I didn't
sit down to plan that it was just like
oh this one's talking to me now oh now
that one okay I guess we're doing a lot
of points of view here but then some are
just one straight point of view some
third person some first that's really I
I don't really know how that
happens well the POV is it of usually
the criminal the detective the victim
I've done all you've done all okay so
there's no hard and fast rule not for me
I
think you know I I think it's and I've
heard other writers say this too the way
a story comes to you because you know as
writers we're just sort of always
um for me anyway I'm like story just
kind of comes in different ways I may
not even be thinking about oh what's my
next story and it just sort of comes at
me and approaches me and
that in that way that a story comes to a
person I I believe
is guides how it gets told and it sounds
very general but if I'm attracted to a
story was originally attracted to the
the story of hole in the woods because
of the victim and that was a very
haunting sto personal story for me it's
a based on a true story and I got to
know the victim's father a bit
and was tracking for years cuz it was a
Cold
Case her story so it was very interested
in it it started with her um so she gets
a point of view I naturally had to tell
her point of view because the more I got
to know her and her family it just had
to happen but that story is also told
through
investigators and it's also told through
the Killer's eyes um because I thought
that they were very had a very
interesting point of view once I got to
kind of
understand or get maybe just know a few
more facts about what they did and who
they were
um so I think it just depends on how a
story comes to you another story that
I'm working on which is a historical
like historical CSI set in France the
story came to me through the main
investigator
and who's male and I typically tell
female prot I typically have female
protagonists so that's been interesting
to to and then I studied his life and so
I became so interested in his life that
it just that's how the story started to
unfold kind of more about his point of
view of how he came up with all these
crime solving
techniques
so yeah when the story opens is there a
a rule of usually is it from the POV of
the victim or again there's no it just
depends on the story it really just
depends on the and the story type it
depends on the story how it came to you
and I think also the story type but I do
believe that you have to set up what
I've noticed about really pretty much
any Crime Story type that I've studied
whe whatever genre whatever tone setting
is you obviously you have to set up the
stakes and the stakes are always
typically murder somebody's been killed
there's there's a crime that needs
investigating so the crime is always set
up very
quickly if not within the first page
then very soon
after so and that that goes back to sort
of um come in in the middle get out
early right coming late exactly and you
know sometimes you see it from the
investigator's point of view sometimes
you see it from the victim's point of
view
um yeah some sometimes it just depend
sometimes it's from the criminals point
of view I'm thinking more of novels
typically do that but yeah just but but
you're you're getting that set up like
pretty fast pretty
quickly can we talk about a character
that's under duress from guilt whether
it's guilt from a crime whether it's
guilt for not saying something uh
whether it's guilt for maybe overlooking
evidence it was a book that I just read
and it's all told from the protagonist
point of view but we find out I'm just
going to spoil it because I have to um
but we find out as we journey through
the story with him that he is also the
killer um and he's telling us this story
because he is so riddled with guilt and
and so and and really the way that the
killing happened was um
very accidental coincidental so it's not
like a you know premeditated hardboiled
kind of murder it it unfolds as sort of
an unfortunate series of events that he
caused and he's completely riddled with
guilt about it um so in a sense like
that drives the I mean really drives the
story and and the investigation that he
does if I could go to prisoners and talk
about
guilt uh prisoners is a really
interesting case study in
guilt
uh a crime is
committed and there are two protagonists
two investigators so it's also very
interesting just a very interesting case
study in in a very unusual story set up
with two protagonist ists who are Jake
jonal and Hugh Jackman one is a
traditional detective so you have a very
traditional cop mystery kind tracing
down Trails of evidence and then you
have Hugh Jackman's character who's a
father and his daughter's been kidnapped
and now he's going to investigate to
find his daughter because he doesn't
think the cops are doing enough um and
then his friend's daughter is also been
kidnapped so you have two sets of
parents and they're all riddled with
guilt in the way that they're handling
they all handle the investigation very
differently and they all become very
guilt-ridden in terms the guilt grows in
terms of what they are doing what
they're not doing what they should be
doing what they shouldn't be doing so
it's it's a very very um that one is
such a good example of of how guilt
plays a very big role in driving what a
character does I guess or doesn't do I
think you do see in in
most uh crime stories at least one of
the characters has an element of guilt
that they're dealing with and that will
drive that person to hide
themsel stay out of you right or hide
something hide information um it will
drive them
to nervous actions just nervousness and
these could be physical reactions like
sweating or
um uh jitteriness un uneasiness like if
you're looking for visual character
things you could go to that extreme
which is an interesting obstacle to
provide your story because now you have
somebody basically a witness to
something has gone missing so if a
person is so driven to guilt there's
usually a reason why and it's usually
connected to the case in some way and
now that connection is severed so that's
a great obstacle for an investigat to
deal with
um it's yeah so
there's there's physical manifestations
there's a lot of I think
guilt the man manifestations of that is
hiding whatever that hiding looks like
for that person again whether it's
hiding themselves hiding information um
hiding someone else um that's it's that
you know wanting to cover things up
right wanting to keep it quiet and
unexposed we talk about the role of a
journalist in a mystery or thriller how
active are they how much are they seen
as the antagonist at times or the hero
depending on the POV of the characters
right right um are you saying a
journalist who's not the protagonist
then or that's a good point yeah I guess
some someone who's maybe a side
character right and how much are they
allowed to be part of a certain ride in
in solving a case or maybe they're seen
as the pesky please stay out of the way
you're you're ruining for us you know I
mean that's those are right real things
that happen exact I love um I think that
the journalist serves as the type of
character who can do things and be
things and be places and into things
that a legal investigator somebody under
the authority of the law like an FBI
agent or detective can't do right
because those protagonists typically
have to work within the confines of the
law what their job you know the legal
confines that we have but journalists
um you know they can get away with a
little bit more amateur detectives
they're I mean they would be considered
and amateur detective and so any amateur
detective can sort of get away with a
few more things so that's fun for a
writer or Creator to play with you're
you're
giving this other Outlet to the
investigating the crime you're also they
can be pesky as you say and that gives a
nice obstacle to the
investigator I don't competition sorry
or competition yep yep yep um
yeah it's I think it's really fun um I
think they need to have a reason for
being there other than like this is my
job and my editor assigned me to it I
mean okay that can be the surface reason
fine but like it just makes it a little
more interesting like what's the real
reason you're so in involved in this
particular crime like always giving our
characters other layers of
motivation you know
what happens in act one of a crime drama
yes act one of a crime drama so much
happens right so we're meeting everybody
all our main characters protagonist hero
um or sorry antagonist protagonist we're
meeting our victim we're meeting people
surround that surrounded the victim
we're meeting a few just a few we're
setting up the tone we're setting up the
world we're setting up the why why this
crime why this person why this
investigator maybe even why this
criminal or at least we're setting up
those questions because there's
different ways you can tell there's four
kind of ways you can tell a crime story
so we're setting up the basics of all
that we are getting into some clues that
are going to be false so we give we're
get we're getting a few hints as to
maybe how and why this person died um
couple those are not going to pan out
meeting different suspects a couple new
you know the kind of the preliminary
Persons of Interest and um then by the
end of act one we're sort of crushing
that um for our detective and I use the
detective as any you know any person
who's investigating where this person
thinks they know what's happening with
with the crime or they think they're on
the right track and it's going to get
blown out of the water and so when when
they launch to act to they're going to
have to come up with a whole new kind
way of of trying to go about
this what are the best ways to introduce
detectives o the best ways so individual
right depending on who that character is
um but I I like to when I'm first trying
to create um a protagonist I I want to
know what they're secret is their pet
peeve uh what kind of Quirk they have I
want to know what devil they have to
fight and I want to know their strength
and their weakness so I'm trying to put
all that into when I'm introducing them
within that First Act um th those are
just kind of my my checklist and then of
course we go deeper into all that but I
think if we can hit all that we're we're
we're doing pretty good and we're
showing our audience that hey this is
somebody we haven't seen before this is
kind of
interesting and then at some point we
would do the same with the
antagonist at some point yes yep and
that can get rolled out a little bit
more slowly um and it can get rolled out
through the eyes of the crime as well so
even if we don't beat our antagonist for
a while we start to get a Feeling or of
what kind of person this is you know
based on how they committed the crime um
evidence maybe that was left behind um
what people are saying about the victim
and maybe people that the victim knew so
how does act one
end um act
one I think needs to end with a bit of
frustration for the protagonist
a bit of uh
suspense um definitely a question mark
this whatever you you thought happened
to this victim were ending act one with
a oh no that's not it there's a big
question mark there's way more to this
story than I thought kind of a question
mark and could that also be in terms of
um access like whether it's the POV of a
family member or or or a detective that
they they think that the access to solve
something or get information those doors
are closed yes it could be the closed
doors of access it could be the closed
doors of a piece of evidence they
thought was key you know we're going to
you know this is it we're going to
figure it out um it can be many yeah any
of those things maybe they even have a
suspect in custody and then NOP The
Alibi pans out and they're off now we're
at we're back at square one what are the
major beats of to in a crime
drama they they're honestly really the
same as any other type of script you're
going to follow the same beats like I'm
very much a save the cat kind of writer
I I use that as the skeleton of my story
I follow all those beats except that
when I'm laying out the actual case
those beats always pertain to my case
and my crime and my protagonist so um
you know we we we're going to start the
beginning of act
two with we're going to have to go over
go after all new evidence and all new
people to talk to because it just didn't
pan out in act one by the midpoint it
looks like we may have somebody okay we
it's all kind of coming to a nice little
head of of I think we got the person
we're looking for and then by the end of
act to everything's crumbled so and not
just crumbled like this is all not
panning out are not on the right track
but our now by the end of act two that
kind of all hope is lost moment our
investigator's life is being threatened
they may it looks like not only are they
going to lose the case but now they're
going to lose their life they've been
kidnapped they've been injured they're
being held up whatever however you want
to do it they're not going to get it
they're not going to get this case
solved that's so really follows the same
but just case all all about the case how
common is it for at least one suspect to
Disappear by the second act by the
second by theend for a suspect to dis
like like die disappear or or maybe
they've just kind of been ruled out like
you said their Alibi checks out and or
or you know whatever it is right but I
mean by the end of act two you should
probably have three to four suspects who
have not checked out who have are done
like you're you're going to run run
through three to four um because by the
beginning of act three your
investigators is going to regroup and
get themselves back on the right track
and oh wait now I figured out who's
really the real person now we need to go
after that
person um and then maybe they figured it
out who knows they may have figured out
some of that before but they can't quite
get there so act three is about actually
getting the real um killer but you're
going to dispose of probably three or
four before you get to the the real one
and how important is it to reach the
wrong solution in act
three
um act three I don't believe is really
about reaching the wrong solution um I
think it's more about because you've
already had a chance to do that and
wanted to or you should be doing that
and wanted to by act three you're coming
up with a final battle plan now you've
got it kind of figured out and it's it's
really more about that battle plan and
executing that battle plan to really go
in and
get the real killer the
real um
suspect so it becomes more
about um figuring out that plan
executing that plan there may be some
you know up and down in that plan it
looks like it's you know there's a
little bit of tension and or a lot of
tension in act three but it's more about
actually T honing in your Target on the
real um criminal and getting them how
important is it to have an overlooked
clue yes there should be I think because
you don't want your hero to
be uh super smart you want them to be
super smart but you want them to be
human and humans we Overlook things um
so I do think there should be you know
it's not act one is a nice place like by
the end of act one by the somewhere in
act two is always a nice place sometimes
it can even happen in act three where
all of a sudden you know something comes
to light that they hadn't considered
before or that wasn't present before or
whatever the reason however you get it
there um that that can be part of their
their final plan where oh we we didn't
see that before and now that helps us
collect all these pieces and now we know
how to catch the killer so
must there always be a confrontation in
act three yes yep I it's we're talking
about flat old good and evil here this
is like crime is you know good versus
evil and so yes there always has to be
uh that battle right between good versus
evil because again we're talking about
the world of chaos and Injustice and um
that has to be writed so there going to
be a battle Good and
Evil
and how do we know we have a satisfying
ending how do we know we have a
satisfying
ending we know we have a satisfying
ending when
whatever chaos or Injustice was set up
at the beginning is now ordered is now
writed is now somehow
redeemed um and this happens even in
Capers um even when the bad guy wins or
loses in capers ERS because you're
whatever you're setting up it even I'm I
keep thinking of Hower High Water
because there's this really bad
Injustice that's set up at the beginning
with the mother of these two brothers
and by the end
uh the criminals who are our bad guys
these brothers but we're rooting for
them right they do this thing this
criminal activity and even though
um there's a big sacrifice that happens
big sacrifice that happens to one of
them the mother's situation is writed
it's restored and so there always is the
sacrifice right there's always some sort
of sacrifice that happens but we know
it's satisfying because whatever is set
up at the beginning is this is not right
this is chaos this is we need this
redeemed that thing is redeemed at the
end so whether it's big or
little what does the acronym MOM stand
for and how does it affect crime writing
yes so in in crime writing the acronym
mom stands for means opportunity and
motive so how does your criminal gain
the means to commit a crime so if
they're killing somebody with a knife H
where do they get the knife from who how
do they bring it to wherever or if it's
a gun or whatever how or if they're
drowning someone how do they you know
how do
where are they doing that what I know it
sounds simple but you do have to
orchestrate that what are the means to
committing this crime um and then
opportunity is simply like a criminal
needs to have access to a victim so how
is that access given
granted H how does it happen um and so
that needs to be thought through um so
you know are they neighbors or people
who work together is it two spouses
again just what is and you know there's
like us people don't always have access
to us so how would they gain access to
us at a time when maybe they shouldn't
have or wouldn't necessarily have access
to us um so like if we're in a locked
vehicle sitting in a parking
lot we should be pretty safe right but
how could well we think How could
somebody gain an opportunity to access
us well they could break the window they
could pop the tire they could you know
Jimmy the door however so that's
opportunity there has to be an
opportunity um for that access uh and
then me motive is the biggie I think and
that's just
why what is the reason behind this crime
and I always when I'm teaching this I
always I'm like okay let's what's the
motive a wife a wife kills a
lover okay or a woman kills a lover her
what's the reason why did she do it oh
she was jealous okay that's a starting
point that's the surface let's go beyond
that well why is she jealous oh well um
I don't know he was cheating on her
we'll just go with a very cliche well
why was he cheating on her if she's so
great why was he cheating well he she
cheated on him oh well why did she cheat
on him oh well because and then we go we
keep going deeper deeper deeper we go
all the way back to Childhood if we have
to because um sharp
objects all that stuff that happened
goes stems way back to things that
happened to her as a child and so that's
the motive that's the building of of the
motive um for the crime and the deeper
and more layered and intricate you get
that will help you really quickly inform
the rest of your story and we help you
really quickly um work through that
second act which which is always a
challenge because you you'll know so
much
about why a person committed a certain
crime um and because a lot of crimes are
Done In the Heat of the Moment some are
premeditated but um it's uh this this
book I was telling about I believe it's
called the patient with the we're
following the killer you go back into
his history so much and find out and her
and the and the the victim's history and
you find out out why he actually did
this so that by the end you're like wow
I'm really sympathetic towards him I get
why he did that um and that's what you
want right you want that deeper
understanding of of the crime and the
criminal
and and
yeah how does setting affect
mystery we talked earlier about a SP
Town yes I love setting for me I almost
think that comes first more so than
character or even the crime um oh man
this is such a cool place well what if
there was a murder here or I think
setting can be its own character I mean
knives out right that that setting is
its own character that whole place um
Breaking Bad that desert setting that
small town is its own character um in
sharp objects that town is its own
character
um the croads uh where are the croads
that setting of the marsh is its own
character and it lends itself to the
crime and how she was able to gain means
opportunity means and opportunity
to dispose of kill and dispose of her
victim um so and even what the marsh
taught her about how to live in the
marsh so that she could
uh get away with it so I think it's it
can be entirely its
own um aspect to the
story what kinds of characters best fit
into a mystery really again I'll just go
back to like it can be any type of
character the important thing is to give
them really great
motive really get really spend time in
the character development because I
found at first when I started doing this
genre I was very much a plotter and I
was like it was all about the plot and
like getting the all the trails of
evidence right and making it this like
really interesting weird twisty murder
or just making sure that the murder just
made sense right and that the trails of
evidence made sense and that the
protagonist could find them all and like
tying you know like a big jigsaw puzzle
you know pinging pinging the pieces
together and then I quickly realized
through
feedback
that that wasn't near enough that was
interesting to a point but it didn't
make it competitive it didn't make it
binge worthy didn't make it
sellable and that's where we want to be
right we want to be
sellable and I started to see that it
while that was all very important to
know that to be authentic in your
forensics and be authentic in your crime
telling and authentic in your your
detectives and what they do and your
protagonists and how a crime is
investigated
what what people are left with more than
that and even and obvious me too
obviously as a as a viewer and a reader
you're left with who were those people
who were those
characters and that's when I had to kind
of all right to bump The Next Step Next
Level writing and really start paying
more attention to the emotional journey
and Heroes Journey arcs of my characters
and that's where motive and
really developing deeper level
characters especially if you're writing
a series right um whether it's a limited
series or series you hope goes on and on
you want to stick with characters that
are very interesting and memorable and
so any character will do but it has to
be I mean any type of person or
character you have to find that thing
that makes
them uh memorable and unique and only
you can do that because we all come from
these very different backgrounds and
very different everybody has very
different experiences and we've all
lived in different Geographic places and
all of that can
inform who you create as a character
it's not something anybody can give give
you or teach you or tell you you have to
start digging
into your own
experiences to help you create those
characters and what is a red herring and
how does it factor into Mysteries red
herring is simply a thing that doesn't
pan out so investigator is like oh I've
got this you know this fingerprint I'm
going to chase after that and they go
and they chase after and they find oh no
actually it's just the next door
neighbor and she was home with the kids
and she has an alibi so that's that's an
example a red herring it's just piece of
evidence that just you know takes you in
the wrong direction for a second and
then doesn't pan out so it wouldn't be
characters because I was thinking about
some of the characters all of them like
sort of like there were five and they
all had their own motives but you don't
know we haven't narrowed down who it is
yet no it it could actually be a
character you think this one character
is it and they turn out to be a red
herring y so it could be evidence could
be a person yep oh okay okay great U
what about rabbit holes rabbit holes are
well we've all been down rabbit holes
and at the end of The Rabbit Hole
there's just a hole there's nothing
there so no but I mean in in crime
writing you want your investigators to
be like little rabbits going after what
they think is the right clue but at the
end they're just a whole it's nothing
and now they got to climb out of the
hole and they got to try another Trail
um you know so we you know just think
about how in real life sometimes we if
we're on the computer we're surfing we
end up going down this crazy I was just
looking for shoes and somehow now I'm
going to Hawaii like how did that happen
so yeah and how much do you like to
foreshadow in a story and what does that
mean yeah that's a good
question I don't think about it at all
in crime writing that's funny I think
about it in drama
writing but that's fun funny question
good question I don't think about
foreshadowing at all in crime writing
what is foreshadowing I mean to me it's
you're sort of layering a hint of
something to
come
and I I'm just thinking about all like
crime other crime writing books or
things that I've I don't think we talk
about it much in this genre because you
don't want to do that necessarily like
you don't want to hint you don't want to
give us a hint about something that's to
come you want to constantly trick us or
take us down a you know make us think
we're going this way when actually it's
over here so I I think it's a great
literary device and I definitely use it
for that for more literary dramatic
writing you definitely want to S put
foreshadowing and symbols of things but
I don't do it at I don't think I use it
at all and that I'm aware of
so when should a writer decide if
they're writing a crime series or a
standalone
story when their agent tells them okay
that's that's a good answer um yes so
most literary agents are looking for
writers who can deliver a series because
there's longevity to that most
publishers are looking for writers who
can deliver a series because they're
longe there's longevity and when you
start to invest in a writer whether an
agent or a publisher like you it takes a
lot to invest into into in a writer um
and so they want writers who they're
this is a career this is something
they're going to be doing for a while um
and going to be producing many works so
that they can foster this career and
make money so
I know when I've worked with my agent
almost everything we've pitched sold is
all based on a series um almost
everything uh now I know a lot of Indie
writers or hybrid authors and they write
series because when that's the only way
you can really make money is if you're
continuing to pump out the next book and
the next book and the next book and it
starts to gather like a snowball down
the mountain and then the residuals you
know and the money gets bigger and
bigger
so
um it's not it's not purely Financial
but also I most authors that I know that
are doing
this they really want to spend time in a
series they really want to develop a
character and keep it going and readers
love that readers want want that they
want to invest and once they've invested
in a book or an author they want the
next one and the next you know it's it's
something they really love and enjoy
they want more you know people will
email me readers will email when's the
next book coming when we want more of
Emily we want more what's
happening so there's there's a lot of
reasons why I think a series is a good
choice a standalone um I wrote a
standalone it and we published it in
2020 I that one was a standalone because
for that was a real passion project for
me I never saw it as a series and I was
already established as a an author and
so I could sort of take the risk you
know of publishing the standalone book
Because I had other things in my
repertoire um and I think the authors
that I know that have published
Standalone it's because it's like that
it's a passion project it's something
that really doesn't lend itself to a
series but it's something they're very
passionate about and they they just need
to write it and and that's fine um and
my agent was fine with that but you know
okay but what's the next series wait
let's let's keep going so yeah is it
easier to write a crime series than
other genres I haven't written in a lot
of other
genres I've done a few things but I
don't know that I give a fair comparison
but I think I always say I think it is a
very challenging genre again because
you're you're having to create a a drama
right with all its intricacies and
levels of characterization and all that
but then you're also having to write a
crime story so it's you're writing two
stories and I I always I start you know
I lay out my Crime Story first so that I
know I have the correct plot then I go
back and I lay out the next the other
Story the par which is the
investigator's story and so what's
because they have personal lives and
they have things that they're dealing
with and so that is a whole separate
story right and then you have to mesh
them together um and figure out how they
how they inform each other so I love it
I love that exercise in the
brain but if I were writing just a
straight
drama I think it would be just the one
story and not another Crime Story
alongside of it so it's challenging
right because in sharp going back to
sharp objects you have Amy Adams
character but then there's a love
interest right and there's kind of
baggage with that and then there's other
people in the town that you kind of get
hints into their world some more than
others right and and yeah it's you you
know so you've got to kind of develop
their little Side Stories exactly
exactly but then you're always pushing
the mystery too like always you have to
have that whole thing figured out so I
like it I uh because I guess maybe I get
bored I like lots of
oriet is creating a crime series as
simple as coming up with new crimes or
that's just one part of it if you have a
protagonist that isn't really going to
change and grow
then it's kind of more about the crimes
that they're solving each book or each
episode right and and we've seen you
know we we've seen that a lot on TV
where um they you know the protagonists
don't have a huge Arc right they just
week by week they're the same person
they don't have a big thing that they're
dealing with um they have their BC and D
stories but you know for the most part
they're they're not changing and growing
a ton they're the same almost the same
people from when they started you know
to the end um so there's that
uh and that's fine that's and then it's
then th with those series or those kinds
of stories the crime becomes very much
in the Forefront that's like really what
we're interest you know we're diving
into those books or that show because we
really are interested in watching the
twisty curvy crime um being solved and
then you have
um the other where I think you're
looking at a protagonist there's a there
maybe is a bigger crime that's being
solved or they're um solving certain
thing you know maybe week by we crimes
but then they're actually dealing with
something kind of bigger in their life
where lifechanging like do doing a
hero's journey where they go from 0 to
180 and they become in some ways a
different person or whatever right devil
that they're fighting or
thing they're trying to overcome they
actually get to overcome it so I think
there's kind of two
directions you can take them so what
goes into the outline of a crime series
I start with my case File which takes a
lot of time I spend most of my time
researching and prepping all this
outline and then uh make sure I have my
crime figured out all the steps of the
crime the logistics of all that how my
investigators going to to solve that and
then the journey that the investigator
is going to go on um and then the
antagonist like what journey is that
antagonist on from the beginning of the
story to the end where where does that
person fit in and what's their Arc so to
me those are the main things that go in
my outline um I outline copiously with
these kinds of
stories um because then when I sit down
to write I can just sort of like ah it's
all it's all kind of there can just pull
it up and now add now get writing um
because I don't want to I'm not a you
know in the fiction World they say
there's the pancer and the plotter and
when it comes to Crime writing I I'm
definitely a plotter because I don't I
don't want
to I don't want to spend my time I want
to spend my time writing not figuring
out does does this evidence work here or
kind of want to get that all figured out
first so I think it's important to
figure the crime out figure out how
those Trails of evidence work how your
investigator is going to run through
that crime and figure it out and and
there will be surprise obviously there's
surprises once she get down to writing
it's it's never finalized in the
outline so what other tips do you have
for anyone deciding to write a crime
series do and don'ts give it a try like
don't think too much if if this is kind
of like your first foray into writing
crime and you're just you're very
interested in it and you love crime just
give it a try I think it's worthwhile
for any writer to to try even if you're
comedy whatever it's such a good
exercise um don't feel that you have to
know everything about forensics or crime
fighting or any of that to to delve in
there's plenty of resources but
do seek to be authentic do some research
get some help if you need need to get
some help in places where you're not
sure about things um and do seek to
entertain
first because that's that's what we're
in the business of doing so if you want
to be a detective go to the police
force if you want to be a writer yeah
but are are there some overused tropes
in terms of um or just like uh just sort
of cliche characters like the the kerin
sergeant who's fighting with the the
other officers but that's not really how
it is or um just the I don't know the
the the jealous ex-wife right that that
we've seen or
ex-husband um or maybe the evil sister
right um you know all of these I
think I think um we I don't know that I
believe in overused tropes as much as
not well played out or well-developed St
stereotypes I do yeah I do think it's
okay to have that chromogen Sergeant
even though that's typically not what
happens in real life because we're not
here to portray necessarily what happens
in real life
but I think it's more of again going
back to why is that Sergeant chromogen
Le against that detective cuz kind of
The Stereotype is just well that's just
their roles like it's just his job to be
a chromogen and and to provide obstacles
for that police officer and it's like
okay that's great that was
1950s whatever but what if we gave that
chromogen
LE uh Sergeant a really good interesting
reason for being chromogen that has
maybe nothing to do with the police
force or maybe it has everything to do
with that officer and there's some
history there um so so again I just
think having motivations for why your
characters are the way they are and
interact the way they
do can go a long way in breaking down
stereotypes but I think the tropes are
like most of the tropes are okay we we
need tropes I mean Trope simply means a
turn right it's just turning the story
in a in a different way to satisfy the
audience's expectations we need that
like we're okay with that as an audience
what we're not okay with is just the
stereotype the the inauthenticity of it
we want to you know especially I think
viewers now are very Savvy and we it's
why why why why are they doing why why
why why is that person acting that way
towards this person
um and yeah so I just like keep
digging